Wohnhäuser werden bombardiert Menschen
getötet Familien auseinandergerissen
seit einem Jahr führt Russland einen
Vernichtungskrieg gegen die Ukraine
wie hat der Krieg das Leben verändert
und was bleibt
ein Gesicht hatte niemand mehr alle 45
Leichen waren ohne Gesicht keine Haare
keine Gesichter alles war verbrannt
wenn man unsere Jungs beerdigt sich die
Hinterbliebenen anschaut dann versteht
man dass man entschiedener handeln muss
tausenden Kindern vergossen was können
die Kinder dafür
reicht ihm Russland nicht
an die Front gehen und dort kann alles
passieren
[Musik]
wir sind Katrin Eigendorf und Jennifer
Girke und wir berichten seit einem Jahr
über den Krieg in der Ukraine von Anfang
an war ich dabei und bin immer wieder
durch das Land gereist da habe ich
erlebt wie sehr der Krieg das Leben der
Menschen zerstört und verändert wir
wollen ja versuchen noch mal mit
Soldaten zu sprechen die wir an der
Front getroffen haben während des
Krieges und wir haben jetzt einfach mal
durchgeguckt und einige von denen sind
tot einige schwerverletzt im Krankenhaus
seit Beginn des Krieges habe ich das
Leben vieler Ukrainer begleitet ich
begegne ihnen über FaceTime Social Media
und Messenger-Dienste jede noch so
schwache Internetverbindung wird genutzt
aus Großstädten und Dörfern suchen Sie
unter schwierigsten Bedingungen den
Kontakt schicken Nachrichten Fotos und
Videos nach all den Monaten reise ich
jetzt durch das Land um sie zu treffen
ich werde Oxana Treffen in rakis die
sechs Monate in Deutschland war Ärztin
ist und zurück will und voll aus dem
Häuschen ist weil sie sich so sehr freut
nach Hause zu kommen und für unser eins
klingt das so absurd oder freust Dich
ins Kriegsgebiet zurückzugehen aber für
sie ist das endlich endlich wieder nach
Hause kommen ich fahre an die Frontlinie
in Richtung der russischen Stadt
Belgorod dort dort möchte ich mich mit
einer Einheit der ukrainischen
Territorialverteidigung treffen
es ist nicht das erste Mal dass ich
Soldaten treffe die ihr Leben in diesem
Krieg riskieren es ist auch für uns
Journalisten mit Gefahren verbunden das
habe ich immer wieder erlebt
[Musik]
auch ihoresnik hat sich bereit erklärt
mir zu zeigen wie seine Einheit kämpft
Russland liegt zum Greifen nah nur einen
Kilometer weit entfernt
die kacksituation wie ist die Situation
heute wir sind unter ständigem Beschuss
man hat mich benachrichtigt dass die
Drohne Orland in der Luft ist für
Aufklärungen normalerweise ist eine
Stunde später der Beschuss es kann jetzt
gefährlich werden
dann werden wir plötzlich beschossen
alle Griechen sofort in den Schutzbunker
über uns sind immer wieder Einschläge zu
hören bedrohlich ich hoffe dass wir hier
unten sicher sind lieber haben sich hier
eingegraben nachdem sie die Russen im
September aus den nahe gelegenen Dörfern
vertrieben haben seit zwei Wochen werden
sie dauerhaft beschossen
sie schießen mit Panzer Artillerie und
auch von Helikoptern wenn sie starten
werden wir informiert das Helikopter in
der Luft sind die kommen nicht hierher
die sind auf ihrem Territorium sie haben
ja auch Angst dass wir sie abschießen
doch auch er hat Angst das erzählte mir
später
nein ich bin kein Militär Mensch und
habe nie gekämpft sobald der Krieg
begonnen hat ging ich zum
Rekrutierungsbüro und habe darum gebeten
dass man mich zu Armee ein Beruf
okay obwohl über uns Artillerie Feuer zu
hören ist beschließen die Männer
herauszugehen im Schutz der Gräben folge
ich eher zu einem Beobachtungsposten
was ist eigentlich das Ziel ihres
Einsatzes hier möchte ich wissen die
Aufgabe besteht darin dass sie nicht auf
das ukrainische Territorium gelangen und
wenn sie mit Panzern hier hinkommen
schießen wir sie ab wir haben
Panzerabwehrwaffen die werden nicht
hierher kommen
auch hier in den schlammigen Gräben wird
der Krieg entschieden die Gefahr ist zu
groß die Männer wollen dass wir die
Stellung verlassen
wir sind hier zu nah sie können uns gut
sehen
haben Sie keine Angst
wir haben uns an die Angst gewöhnt was
wird wenn die Angst uns erobert wer
bleibt dann hier
also für mich als Zivilistin ist es
extrem wir sind alle Zivilisten
ja stimmt wir sind alle Zivilisten
wir können hier nicht weg
dann zeigt Engel das ist mein Talisman
hat mir meine kleine Tochter geschenkt
bei allen Kampfeinsätzen habe ich ihn
dabei
ist mit den jüngeren Kindern nach
Frankreich geflohen seine älteste
Tochter kämpft ebenfalls bei der
Territorialverteidigung
25 Jahre lang war als Zollbeamter jetzt
riskiert er mit 49 Jahren hier sein
Leben
ihor nimmt mich mit zur Kommandozentrale
wir dürfen sie nur von innen zeigen
damit das Gebäude nicht von den Russen
entdeckt werden kann die beobachten Sie
die Stellungen der Feinde und seit
Beginn des Krieges sammeln Sie was die
Russen hinterlassen haben
das sind Bomben die sie mit Fallschirmen
abgeworfen haben
hier steht Russland drauf und die Nummer
des Soldaten ein Kreuz aber
offensichtlich hat es nicht geholfen
vor kurzem haben sie einen russischen
Panzer erbeutet und ihn repariert jetzt
wollen sie ihn gegen die Russen
einsetzen
[Musik]
er ist entschlossen weiterzukämpfen
seine Familie würde sobald nicht
wiedersehen
Lemberg im Westen der Ukraine über
200.000 Ukrainer sind hier hin
geflüchtet in der Hoffnung hier sicher
zu sein auch ihor Doshi
hello es ist Montagmorgen 8 Uhr
begrüßt uns mit Badeschlappen und
Taschenlampe
unsere erste Begegnung im stockdunkel
Strom haben sie hier nur ein paar
Stunden am Tag
der 31-Jährige will nicht in den Krieg
und kämpfen er hat Schlimmes erlebt und
er hat Angst
[Musik]
und das ist unsere Küche wo wir unser
Abendessen kochen
ist einer der Überlebenden des
russischen Angriffs auf den Bahnhof in
grammatos er und seine Verlobte saßen am
8 April im Zug an einem der Gleise als
eine russische Rakete einschlug vor
ihren Augen starben mehr als 50 Menschen
über die grauenvollen Erlebnisse habe
ich mit ihrer wenige Tage danach
gesprochen per telegram er schickte mir
auch Fotos und Videos aufgenommen mit
seinem Handy
von kremators sind sie nach Lemberg
geflohen weit weg von dem Ort des
Grauens
unsere Pläne haben sich radikal
verändert ich habe meiner Freundin einen
Heiratsantrag gemacht und wir wollten im
Sommer heiraten
sie planten ein Leben im Ausland am
liebsten in Tschechien und waren nur
kurz zu einem Familienbesuch in der
Ukraine doch dann wurden sie vom Krieg
überrascht
nun sitzen sie seit 12 Monaten hier fest
als Mann darf ihr Horn nicht ausreisen
und Katja will nicht ohne ihn leben
wenn nicht heute dann werde ich morgen
den Einberufungsbescheid bekommen und
die Militärübungen antreten wir müssen
für den sie kämpfen früher oder später
werden alle absolut alle gezwungen sein
etwas Schweres durch zu machen
die Angst einberufen zu werden begegnet
mir öfter ein Gespräch mit jungen
Männern ihor möchte sein Land
unterstützen aber nicht als Soldat
ich spende das Geld für die Streitkräfte
der Ukraine ich bin nützlich für mein
Land bezahle die Steuern
durch die Steuern wird auch die Armee
versorgt je mehr Geld an sie geht desto
schneller kommt der Sieg so ihre
Hoffnung
in einem kleinen Kellerraum verpackt
Online-Bestellungen
und hier arbeite ich
8 bis 9 Stunden verbringen Sie hier
unten täglich Hobbys interessieren sie
nicht Freunde haben sie keine aber sie
haben sich das ist viel wert der Krieg
habe alles zerstört erzählt auch die
Verbindungen zur Familie ihr Haus Vater
lebt in Russland
ich habe ihm meine Position erklärt dass
ich Russland hasse und nie vergeben
werde
das konnte der Vater nicht verstehen sie
brachen den Kontakt ab
mit meiner Schwester ist es noch
schlimmer selbst mein Vater hasse ich
nicht so hassen ist das falsche Wort ich
bin nicht so sauer auf meinen Vater wie
auf meine Schwester
Jaus Schwester lebte in Mario Paul die
Stadt ist immer noch von Russen besetzt
sie konnte nach Europa fliehen doch ihr
Hort befürchtet dass russische Regime
habe sie manipuliert
habe ich in russischen
propagandistischen Fernsehsendern gehört
[Musik]
sie analysiert die Situation nicht
für Wort was sie im Fernsehen gehört hat
sie sei aber immer noch seine Schwester
die er liebt die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben
dass sie irgendwann erkennt was wirklich
in der Ukraine passiert
als ich Katja Frage ob sie auch eine
eigene Familie gründen wollen kommen die
beiden in Verlegenheit
[Gelächter]
ja das hatten wir geplant
wir können wir über eine eigene Familie
sprechen wenn vor deiner Haustür der
Krieg andauert in jedem Moment kann ich
an die Front gehen und dort kann alles
passieren
[Musik]
nicht schön kämpfen für ihn eine
Horrorvorstellung auch wenn es für sein
Heimatland ist
sollte sich Russland einmal vor einem
internationalen Kriegsgericht
verantworten müssen wird auch isium eine
Rolle spielen hier wurden hunderte
Menschen gezielt durch russische
Angriffe getötet
Halina Zikade war hat ihren Sohn und
seine gesamte Familie verloren acht
Menschen
ich besuche die 71-Jährige in ihrer
Wohnung
danke
sie trinken erstmal Kaffee sind ja eben
erst gekommen und danach arbeiten wir
obwohl es schmerzhaft für sie ist möchte
ralina uns ihre Geschichte erzählen die
Stadt isium wurde sechs Monate von
Russen besetzt war unter Dauerbeschuss
halinas Sohn Alexander wohnte in der
Nähe
er sagte Mama kommt zu uns bei uns ist
es wahr sie ist zu Hause geblieben ihren
Sohn und seine Familie wird sie nie
wieder sehen
nach etwa zwei Tagen hat man mir gesagt
dass ihr Haus zerstört wurde
ich wollte doch nicht weinen
wie kann man nicht weinen wenn man so
etwas erlebt hat
wissen Sie ich habe irgendwie gespürt
dass sie nicht mehr am Leben sind
wenn er weggefahren wäre wäre er
gekommen um mich abzuholen ganz klar er
würde mich nie hier zurücklassen
und dann bin ich hingegangen zweimal bin
ich hingegangen
die Familie hatte mit vielen anderen
Menschen Schutz im Keller des Hauses
gesucht die russischen Raketen schlugen
genau dort ein
wenn sie in der Wohnung geblieben wären
hätten sie überlebt die Enkelin und der
Sohn mit seiner Familie sie wären jetzt
noch am Leben
weil niemand Gerät hatte um die Leichen
zu bergen lagen die Menschen unter den
Trümmern erst Wochen später wurden sie
geborgen Alina war dabei sie wollte
Gewissheit
insgesamt habe ich sechs identifiziert
die kleinere Enkelin und meine
Schwiegertochter habe ich nicht erkannt
verbrannt erschlagen zerfetzt so lagen
die Körper der Toten in den Trümmern
[Musik]
ein Gesicht hatte niemand mehr alle 45
Leichen waren ohne Gesicht keine Haare
keine Gesichter alles verbrannt die
Kleidung auch
nur mein Sohn hatte noch ein Gesicht ein
Rohr hatte ihn geschützt
als isium im September befreit wurde
entdeckten die Ukraine dutzende Gräber
in einem Wald am Stadtrand die Bilder
gingen um die Welt es war für mich eine
der grauenvollsten Erlebnisse des
Krieges
Journalisten aus aller Welt waren damals
dabei als Ermittlungsteams die Gräber
aushoben 450 Menschen darunter auch
Kinder
in Plastiksäcken wurden sie nach hakif
gebracht Untersuchung von
Kriegsverbrechen die noch nicht
abgeschlossen sind ich bin zurückgekehrt
der Geruch des Todes der damals über den
Gräbern lag ist gewichen doch noch immer
liegt eine gespenstische Atmosphäre über
dem kiefernhain
die Gräber sind noch nicht geschlossen
einige Holzkreuze stehen noch und
Hinterbliebene haben Erinnerungen
hinterlassen
[Musik]
viele Menschen suchen nach wie vor nach
ihren Angehörigen in einer
provisorischen Polizeistation in Isis um
können sie ihre DNA abgeben die mit den
Körpern der 450 Toten abgeglichen wird
eine Arbeit die belastend ist für die
Beamten
wenn man Knochenfragmente von Kindern
findet das Sterben jeder Person tut weh
aber mir als Mutter tun die Kinder
besonders leicht
[Musik]
Enkeltochter wurde nur 13 Jahre alt
ihr Sohn wäre jetzt 50 geworden das
wollte er feiern
Halina hat noch eine Tochter sie lebt in
England und will die Mutter zu sich
holen
aber Halina will in isum bleiben bei den
Toten die sie irgendwann würdig begraben
möchte
[Musik]
eines der ersten Ziele in diesem Krieg
war die Hauptstadt hier auch heute
müssen die Menschen jederzeit mit
Angriffen rechnen hier treffe ich Pastor
Anatoli kalucci
seit Tag eins des Krieges stehen wir in
Kontakt
Lebensmittel Hilfskonvois die Videos die
er mir geschickt hat zeigen wie sich
Menschen hier gegenseitig helfen
seine Kirche ist zu einem Auffangbecken
für geflüchtete geworden alle hier sind
geflohen vertriebene im eigenen Land
wir haben gelebt und hart gearbeitet
und dieser Faschist ist gekommen und hat
uns unser Leben weggenommen
er hat ganze Familien zerstört schon ich
wünschte er sei weg und verdammt
Hanna
einer Stadt die monatelang von den
Russen besetzt war hier kann die
72-Jährige ihren Gefühlen freien Lauf
lassen diese Menschen brauchen Trost
mehr als alles andere erzählt Pastor
Anatoli
manche denken an Selbstmord das ist am
schlimmsten wenn Menschen nicht mehr
leben wollen
seine Botschaft seit zuversichtlich
vertraut Gott und vor allem geht nicht
auf
wir sind wie David und Goliat david war
ein junger Kerl und Goliat stark wie
russ Land und wir glauben dass Gott uns
helfen wird und die Ukraine gewinnen
wird diese Hoffnung bringen wir in die
Herzen der Menschen und helfen ihnen
stark zu sein
die Ukraine brauche ein Wunder um ihren
Goliath zu besiegen dafür betet Anatoli
jeden Tag
am nächsten Tag fahre ich nach brodjanka
60 Kilometer von Kiew auch hier
begleitet mich mein ukrainische Kollegin
Alexandra
die Wunden dieses brutalen Krieges sind
auch nach einem Jahr offensichtlich
[Musik]
in einem kleinen Gemeinderaum treffen
sich Einwohner der Stadt um Tarnnetze
für die Armee zu flechten
auch Olga chrisak macht mit
sie ist 91 Jahre alt war früher
Russischlehrerin in einer Schule
50 Jahre habe ich die Kinder
unterrichtet ihnen beigebracht klug
Weise und gütig zu sein
ich habe auf ein glückliches Ende
gehofft auf ein glückliches Leben
und so ist es jetzt gekommen wir müssen
durchhalten auch das noch müssen wir
durchstehen
olga hat den Zweiten Weltkrieg als Kind
erlebt das Kinder jetzt durch Putins
Angriff ein solches Elend erleben müssen
macht sie wütend
wofür werden die Tränen von tausenden
Kindern vergossen was können die Kinder
dafür
reicht ihm Russland nicht
kann dieses russische Land ihn nicht im
Halse stecken bleiben es ist lange
fällig dass es ihm im Hals stecken
bleibt
am 1 März schlugen drei Bomben in ihre
Wohnsiedlung sie will mir das Haus
zeigen ihre Tochter und eine Nachbarin
begleiten uns
5 Etage dieses große Fenster ist unser
Wohnzimmer
dann möchte Olga zu ihrer Wohnung Stufe
für Stufe zieht sie sich nach oben
im dritten Stock hält die Nachbarin an
und zeigt uns was von ihrer Wohnung noch
übrig geblieben ist
[Applaus]
doch weiter hoch sollen wir nicht
warum darf ich nicht weitergehen man
darf nicht weiter darf man nicht gehen
die Decke oben ist eingestürzt wir haben
viele Passage
olga war einer der ersten BewohnerInnen
in diesem Haus
in der Nacht in der sie bombardiert
wurden konnte sie nichts mitnehmen sie
musste sofort raus und auch heute kann
sie nicht zurück
nach Hause
viele der geflüchteten die ich getroffen
habe kommen aus razon monatelang lebten
sie unter russischer Besatzung wie ist
das Leben dort heute
[Musik]
ich besuche die Eltern von Katharina
Jenko
wir sind gefangen in unserer Stadt wir
sind gefangen in unseren eigenen Häusern
wir sind Gefangene und wir sind machtlos
das hier ist unser Unterschlupf wo wir
schlafen
[Musik]
die 31-Jährige und ich stehen seit einem
Jahr in Kontakt sie hat mir viele Bilder
aus der Besatzungszeit geschickt eine
große Angst damals nicht zu wissen ob
sie jemals wieder ihren Freund sehen
würde anders ist Däne die beiden führten
eine Fernbeziehung
ich schreibe meinem Freund die ganze
Zeit dass ich ihn liebe weil ich nicht
weiß welche Nachricht
welche Nachricht die letzte sein wird
Mitte März ist Katharina geflohen
seitdem lebt sie mit ihrem Freund in
Dänemark ihre Eltern musste sie
zurücklassen sie wollten nicht mit
[Musik]
presson liegt nahe der Front hier kann
es gefährlich werden ich ziehe meine
Schutzweste an
Vater verladislav macht das Tor nur kurz
auf die Straße sollen wir nicht filmen
niemand kann sicher sein dass die Russen
nicht zurückkommen
kommt rein kommt rein bitte
ihr Haus ist nur 3 km von der Front
entfernt jeden Tag hören Sie
raketeneinschläge
das hat mir Katja in den Videos gezeigt
ihr habt ihr euch versteckt oder
ich erkenne den Unterschlupf was den
Videos wieder hier haben sie zwei Monate
geschlafen
gar nichts darunter nur fliegen
Blechtafeln das war mal unser Metalltor
das war für den Fall dass wenn die Decke
runterfällt wer nicht verschüttet werden
das ist unser Überwachungssystem das hat
Blatt alles selbst gemacht durch die
Kameras konnten sie die russischen
Soldaten beobachten
fuhren mit ihren gepanzerten
Transportwagen mit Lastwagen
haben ihre Scheinwerfer auf unsere
Fenster gerichtet
sie fuhren die Straßen entlang das war
sehr unheimlich als ob man in deinem
Haus mit schmutzigen Stiefeln herumläuft
dann gehen Sie mit mir in das Zimmer
ihrer Tochter
alles ist aufgeräumt das Bett bezogen
als ob Katharina gleich wiederkäme
an der Wand hänge noch die Lernzettel
mit dänisch Vokabeln
[Musik]
die Sehnsucht nach seinem einzigen Kind
zu schmerzhaft
beruhige dich atme tief durch
mama Papa ihr seid meine Helden ich bin
sehr stolz auf euch ich vermisse euch so
sehr ich hoffe dass das alles bald zu
Ende ist und ich euch umarmen kann
sogar bei der Beerdigung meiner Mutter
habe ich nicht so viel geweint wie jetzt
ihr größter Trost zu sehen dass ihre
Tochter in Sicherheit ist
wie ging das Leben unter der Besatzung
dann weiter
niemand wusste was zu tun ist was darf
man was darf man nicht
ich weiß nicht womit ich das vergleichen
kann du lebst in deinem Haus aber du
sollst jemanden um Erlaubnis bitten und
fragen was Du tun darfst
am 11 November wurde Herr Sonne von der
ukrainischen Armee befreit
doch sicher fühlen sie sich nicht
als ich draußen war hörte ich die
Granaten über mir irgendwo sind sie
runtergefallen ich weiß nicht wo genau
irgendwo in unserem Viertel das macht
mir große Angst
die meisten Menschen aus Restaurant sind
geflohen von knapp 280.000 Einwohnern
sind weniger als 60.000 geblieben
ich fahre ins Zentrum eine Geisterstadt
man hat Angst dass man jederzeit sterben
kann sonst ist alles in Ordnung
wenn wir alle weg sind was werden unsere
Soldaten verteidigen eine Stadt besteht
aus Menschen nicht nur aus Gebäuden wir
bleiben hier
sich nicht vertreiben lassen so
reagieren viele Ukraine auf diesen Krieg
Ladislav und Lena werden nicht weggehen
auch nicht ihre Tochter zuliebe aber
Katharina besuchen das werden sie wenn
der Krieg gewonnen ist
ich fahre nach niebro hier bin ich
verabredet mit einem Soldaten der
Territorialverteidigung
betrafen ihn Ende Juni im Südwesten von
Donezk seine Truppe kämpfte direkt an
der Front
wir fahren los und im Falle eines
Beschusses was bei der momentanen Lage
nicht passieren dürfte halten wir das
Fahrzeug sofort an alle steigen aus und
legen sich auf den Boden
Skipper war mir sofort sympathisch
selbstbewusst und gerade heraus
er nennt sich immer noch Skipper sein
kampfname aber kämpfen kann er nicht
mehr er wurde schwer verletzt ja ich
erhielt bereits den Befehl für die
Mobilisierung ich kehre langsam zum
zivilen Leben zurück
wie ist das für sie
es ist schwer psychisch ist es schwer
der 43-Jährige lag monatelang im
Krankenhaus
von seiner 30 mannstarken Einheit sind
nur noch zehn im Einsatz zwei sind tot
18 sind so stark verwundet dass sie
nicht mehr zurück an die Front können
eigentlich wollten wir seine frühere
Einheit besuchen doch das ist nicht mehr
möglich
es ist sehr gefährlich die Siedlungen wo
wir uns damals getroffen haben werden
jetzt heftig bombardiert
es ist schwerer Waffeneinsatz die Jungs
sind in Kampfposition
bei unserem Besuch damals war die Lage
etwas ruhiger
ihre Botschaft damals wir brauchen
dringend westliche Waffen
wir haben sie zurückgedrängt so zwei bis
drei Kilometer die Erfolge sind so
gering weil wir ausschließlich leichte
Schusswaffen haben
sie waren sich alle einig der Westen
liefere zu spät und zu wenig
mittlerweile sind einige Monate
vergangen Deutschland liefert jetzt auch
Leopard Panzer die Debatten darüber hat
Kipper genau verfolgt
wenn man unsere Jungs beerdigt sich die
Hinterbliebenen anschaut
versteht man dass man entschiedener
handeln muss
Keeper hat einen seiner Kameraden
verloren er nannte sich Vomer ich hatte
ihn im Sommer auch kennengelernt
das ist ein Foto von fuma wenn sie sich
an ihn erinnern können er ist gefallen
er ist gefallen ja genau
er hat mir noch erzählt dass er nach dem
Krieg in Deutschland arbeiten will
damals von den Gefahren erzählt
sie schießen aus großer Entfernung die
Geschütze stehen 20 Kilometer von hier
und schießen in diese Richtung
kurz nach unserem Besuch griffen die
Russen an Oma wurde getötet der
Familienvater wurde 62 Jahre alt er
hinterlässt seine Frau und Kinder auch
Skiba hat drei Söhne der älteste geht in
die Militärschule der Tod seines
Kameraden die Verluste all das macht ihm
schwer zu schaffen ob er die
Entscheidung zu kämpfen bereut frage ich
ihn nein ich würde mich wieder genauso
entscheiden
Skipper möchte wieder in seinem Beruf
als Anwalt arbeiten jetzt will er sich
auf das Bauwesen spezialisieren das Land
muss wieder aufgebaut werden dabei will
er mithelfen
[Musik]
mein letztes Ziel ist rakiv die
Großstadt im Osten wurde schon in den
ersten Monaten des Krieges heftig
bombardiert
Oxana Michael schuk Flo damals nach
Deutschland jetzt ist die Ärztin zurück
[Applaus]
noch im März setzte sie jeden Tag ihr
Leben aufs Spiel um ihre Patienten zu
behandeln
unsere Gespräche führte Oxana meistens
aus dem Bunker dort war die
Internetverbindung am stabilsten auch
bei Beschuss
[Musik]
aber man gewöhnt sich dran
eine Rakete zerstörte ihre Wohnung die
Versorgungslage in der Stadt wurde immer
dramatischer
im Mai entschied sie sich zu fliehen und
fuhr bis nach Stade in Niedersachsen
[Musik]
sie wollte als Radiologe in einer Klinik
arbeiten ein neues Leben aufbauen
[Musik]
doch die Sehnsucht vergrößert als
gedacht wir treffen uns vor ihrem Haus
zum ersten Mal kehrt sie in ihre
zerstörte Wohnung zurück
die Heizung funktioniert einige Fenster
wurden erneuert
überall hier waren solche Splitter
hier sie sind bis zum Schrank geflogen
die Splitter haben es bis dorthin
geschafft
ein Wunder dass das Haus nicht
abgebrannt ist
da sieht man noch richtig die Löcher ne
Oksana war nicht zu Hause als die
Geschosse einschlugen
es wird viel Arbeit alles zu reparieren
so Dusche
macht aber nichts
man kann es hier schon aushalten
ich freue mich dass ich zurück in meinem
Leben bin
wir wissen zwar nicht was morgen
passiert aber für mich ist das ein
wunderbares neues Kapitel
draußen zeigt uns die 45-Jährige ihre
zerstörte Nachbarschaft
das hier ist das berühmte Haus alle
machen Fotos davon es war ein Bombe oder
ja wie sonst konntest du einstürzen
wurde wohl etwas von oben abgeworfen
aber es freut mich dass ihr wieder
gearbeitet wird das macht mich glücklich
wisst ihr alles wird gut wir brauchen
nur Zeit
jederzeit könnten hier wieder Raketen
einschlagen das weiß auch Oxana
der Stadtteil saltifka liegt nur 30 km
von Russland entfernt
[Musik]
beim Länder waren sich immer so nah und
jetzt sieht man dieses Zerstörung die
wie geht sie damit um da musste ich
Lehrer wenn ich Russland hassen oder
meinen Frust rauslassen würde dann
verschwende ich doch nur meine Energie
vorstellen wir treffen sie in einem
Lager für Hilfsgüter wo sich die
31-Jährige um Medikamente kümmert ein
Wiedersehen nach vielen Monaten
da kommt sie
da ist Marina
[Musik]
als ob ich nie weg gewesen wäre als ob
ich es gestern Tschüss gesagt hätte wie
toll
Marina ist geblieben sie brachte es
nicht übers Herz ihre Heimat zu
verlassen
wir hatten immer schon eine enge
Beziehung jetzt ist Oxana zurück und wir
werden weiter zusammen durchs Leben
gehen ja sogar noch besser
gemeinsam setzen sie in ihrem
Lieblingscafé so wie vor dem Krieg
auch wenn es nie wieder so werden wird
wie früher es ist zu Hause
[Musik]
auch die movas Leben in saltifa dem
bevölkerungsreichsten Stadtteil von
hakiff auch sie sind zurückgekehrt
im Juni traf ich sie in der Metrostation
Helden der Arbeit schon am ersten Tag
des Krieges hatten sie hier Schutz vor
den russischen Angriffen gesucht mehr
als 800 Menschen lebten damals in der
Metro
wir machen es unsere häuslich wie
möglich Wäsche waschen putzen essen
wochenlang trauten sie sich kaum heraus
wie ist das für dich hier unten zu leben
ich habe mich schon daran gewöhnt das
ist normal
möchtest du nicht nach Hause
nein
ihr Bruder in die Kita war damals krank
die Feuchtigkeit hatte ihm zugesetzt als
die Stadtverwaltung die Metrostation im
Dezember räumen ließ mussten auch sie
gehen
[Musik]
wir treffen uns in ihrem Haus Diana und
ihr Mann wollten nicht zurückkehren in
der Metro fühlten sie sich sicher
wir wollten noch den Frühling da
verbringen hier ist es doch so
gefährlich
wird weiterhin angegriffen die Sachen
für die U-Bahn sind immer gepackt
wo ist es besser zu Hause oder im
U-Bahnhof mir gefällt es besser zu Hause
mir gefällt es besser im U-Bahnhof
warum
dabei ihre Freundin
und da hörte man die Knallerei nicht
einmal hatte ich meine schwarzen
drahtlosen Kopfhörer in den Ohren habe
die Lautstärke voll aufgedreht und hörte
trotzdem die Knallerei
der Krieg hat ihre Kindheit beendet
Ihnen die Unbeschwertheit genommen viel
zu schnell musste auch Nikita erwachsen
werden doch anders als Anja ist der froh
wieder zu Hause zu sein
warum gefällt es dir besser hier weiß
nicht weil ich keine Angst habe und es
mir hier besser geht
vor allem ärmere Familien haben es jetzt
besonders schwer Janas Familie lebt ohne
Heizung
vor kurzem war es ein Grad bei uns zu
Hause und als es minus 10 Grad draußen
waren ist unsere Teekanne in der Küche
eingefroren
gibt es nur noch Online-Unterricht ohne
Notstrom können sie nicht lernen in der
U-Bahn war das anders
da gab es immer Strom und so auch
Unterricht hier haben wir jeden Tag
Stromausfall um 9 Uhr wenn die Schule
sein soll
die meisten Freunde von Anja und Nikita
sind mit ihren Familien ins Ausland
geflohen auf dem Spielplatz sind wir
allein spontan entscheiden wir ins
Delfinarium zu gehen
ein Teil der Tiere ist evakuiert worden
mit denen die noch da sind werden
Schwimmkurse für Kinder gemacht das soll
ihnen Sicherheit vermitteln
[Musik]
es wirkt skurril und schön zugleich ein
kurzer Augenblick in dem sie Kinder sein
können in diesem Krieg
[Musik]
diese Reise hat gezeigt jeder geht
anders mit dem Schmerz der letzten 12
Monate um mit den Trümmern den äußeren
und den inneren
für mich als Resümee hat eigentlich
diese Zeit hier mir noch mal gezeigt
inwieweit das wirklich ein
Vernichtungskrieg gegen die Ukraine ist
das ist kein Krieg wo es nur um
Territorium geht sondern es ist wirklich
ein vernichtungs-
der größte Zivilisationsbruch den wir
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg erlebt haben
der Krieg in der Ukraine ist in diesen
Wochen an einem Tiefpunkt angelangt wie
lange können die Menschen das noch
aushalten das ist auch etwas was ich
glaube ich immer wieder gehört habe egal
wie schlimm das hier ist und egal wie
viel wir verloren haben aber die Krallen
sich an das Allerletzte was ihn doch
noch bleibt und wenn es die eine Katze
der eine Oper oder die eine Wohnung ist
aber dieses letzte Stückchen zu Hause
was vielleicht doch noch steht daran
krallen sich fest und daran halten Sie
sich fest besser als wegzugehen
ein Jahr Krieg das ist für die Ukraine
auch verbunden mit der Furcht vor einer
neuen Eskalation
Perspektiven für Friedensgespräche gibt
es nicht nur das Ziel Russland zu
besiegen mit Unterstützung des Westens
die Hoffnung dass irgendwann alles
wieder aufgebaut wird dass das Land
Frieden findet